[Musik]
wir nennen den kanal einfach um jetzt
sally freddy kanal besuch shipping
machen dann müssen wir beide namen
zusammen also herzlich willkommen
das ist meiner bereit was mein
fachbereich alles deswegen auch ein
versprechen alles voraussichtlich eher
im bereich produkttester er schafft es
nicht das zu verwenden das müssen wir
anders machen
das schaffen wir schon heute kochen wir
einen eintopf lenker scheuer hotpot ein
rezept aus nordengland was ich auf
interest entdeckt habe und dachte dass
das können wir doch mal kochen und wir
sind jetzt hier in der küche den drüben
in der küche drehen wir aktuell auch
noch parallel wir zwar unsere zwei
anderen nicht gesehen da drüben
jedenfalls glaube ich ist das echt
cooles gericht und wird immer gusseisen
zubereitet das ganze wird auch sehr
schonend gegart und er bei niedrigen
temperaturen wird anscheinend super
butterzart und so weiter und deswegen
machen wir einfach dass parallel weil da
passt jetzt schon viele eine gute
portion rein aber wir sind halt noch
viel mehr menschen da drüben
deswegen machen wir gleich zwei
funktionen wir zeigen euch mal die
zutaten
wir brauchen einen esslöffel butter
einen esslöffel olivenöl 400 gramm
lammfleisch ne zwiebel und knoblauchzehe
etwas mehr karotten die sind bereits
geschält 500 gramm gemüsebrühe einen
esslöffel soße ich erkläre gleich was
dazu kartoffeln die brauche ich nicht
stehlen weil sie einfach gewaschen sind
groß marien thymian lorbeerblätter und
etwas butter
das ist sehr präsent diese soße die hier
ist das ist die soße dich nie
aussprechen kann könnte es gerade ghost
box touristischer sauce es ist einfach
schreibt man wr ces ces or services of
east asia und wir brauchen noch salz und
pfeffer wir statt uns direkt denn wir
haben alle hunger also einfach mal
butter und öl rein
bitter für den geschmack und öl ok also
hier noch hatte mal vielleicht schiebt
oder eine zutaten geschafft als befinde
ich bin gewohnt mit eigentlichen und
dann kann ich das schon mal eher hemmen
erwärmen
das ist fleisch einfach in würfel
schneiden sollte auch nicht zu mager
sein
es tut mir leid ich habe es dir halt
auch echt schwer gemacht und bin auf die
seite mit mir plant finde das gut ich
krieg das schon hin für mich ist im
prinzip symbolisiert die leute die mit
kommen aber auch der boom video
anzuhalten stimmen
wir kochen einfach parallel so ja auf
acht oder so 8 oder so auf 8 passt und
dann das fleisch am besten info 12 cm
würfel
vielleicht kennt ja auch jemand von euch
dieses rezept und kann dann auch
schreiben ob wir alles richtig mache
habe ich nie gemacht
ja ich hab da so ein bild gesehen habe
mich davon inspirieren lassen ich hab
auch ein bisserl was anders weil ich
muss halt immer so meinen eigenen touch
reinbringen und rosmarin weil ich habe
einfach so viel rosmarin im garten dass
ich immer versuche den einfach zu
verwerten ist deine mutter meiner mutter
ist eine echt gute köchin kannst du
schon mal hier
sie war auch schon hier kochen video
wäre eigentlich auch mal ja aber meine
mama ist so scheu und schüchtern und
aber ich müsste eigentlich mal überreden
überreden
und mein papa vielleicht die papas
lieblingsrezept ja schon gut und vor
allem ist der papa mega lustig okay geht
es dann habt dann könnt ihr das fleisch
anbraten
am besten eigentlich das gleich vorher
auf raumtemperatur kommen lassen
[Musik]
dann kann ich schon mal die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen fein würfeln
auf meinem wunderschönen schneidebrett
bin gerade gleich wieder dran
bei mir war ja das sieht gut aus krieg
das schon hin
das sieht gut aus
[Musik]
ja er rein und dann schön anbraten
das müssen sie schon scharf anbraten
dass die roßlauerin kriegen
ich hätte vielleicht glaube ich von
anfang an bis zum herstellen wird unser
video
hier suchen
die farbe soll
wir haben
es ist echt sagen bei dies ist
vielleicht besser aus weil einfach mehr
hitze brauchbar
ich habe vorhin vergessen wieder hoch zu
stellen
euro aus
als fleisch herausnehmen wenn es schön
angebraten ist
und dann die hitze aber gern ein
bisschen reduzieren und die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen und wirklichem erwarten
den sieg nicht mehr so viel hitze
oh ja
und da gebe ich jetzt vom deckel drauf
damit ein bisschen schmoren kann so
jetzt kannst du hier alles ein geben und
ein fleisch sind echt perfekt aus
das ölreiche oder so
du kannst den deckel drauf geben das ist
einfach so ein bisschen sport okay ein
bisschen runter oder ja so auf sex ist
okay die karotten wir mal so in fünf
millimeter scheiben schneiden
die haben wir dann bleiben die sowieso
bis fester und wenn nicht so weit
vielleicht werden sie auch weil wir
lassen sehr lange aber dann ist auch
okay
und dann hoch kurzen schwächeanfall
kann ich schon mal das mehl darüber
geben über die zwiebel mit anbraten
damit die soße gleich ein bisschen
bindet was dein lieblings hat von dir ja
als jetzt ohne bolognese
eigentlich also das eigentliche spätzle
mit ganz viel saurer es habe ich habe
noch nie spätzle auf einem kanal gemacht
und natürlich du da und ich habe einfach
kein speziell für dich gemacht ich hab
ich kann das sehr gut
hier habe ich dir schreibe so schwäbisch
gut wo man dann einfach nur nur dass man
dann einfach nur die teigmasse rein
klopft und manchmal solche abstürze
näher an
also habe ich mit angebraten möchte ich
jetzt dann auch mal machen und dann mit
der brühe ablöschen
dann uns dabei jusos ok mail mit
angeboten ja heute sie nach schwarz wie
schlimm das restaurant
dann brühen
[Musik]
sehr gut aus die hitze kann dann auch
gleich wieder hoch und dann gebe ich
noch die gewürze dazu und zwar die
lorbeerblätter etwas pfeffer den thymian
nicht bitter der kommt nämlich auch die
kartoffeln salz müssen wir gleich mal
abschmecken wegen der gemüsebrühe dann
wird die soße die worcester soße die
bobbauer lorbeeren
dann gebe ich die karotten rein
und stell dich jetzt jetzt doch wieder
runter hat das nicht so arg wort und
gibt es fleisch wetter dazu damit nur
noch ein bisschen siedet möchte dass du
dann dazu die menschen möchten
hast du peruanischen heimat und schult
seit ich lebe jetzt meinen deckel drauf
also deckel wieder drauf und dann kann
ich mich jetzt nicht um die kartoffeln
kümmern und die kartoffeln einfach
gewaschen sind sie in 5 mm scheiben
hobeln und das hole ich jetzt damit sie
gleichmäßig dick werden damit sie
gleichmäßig gar werden gleich wo geräten
dass man das hier oben drauf machen kann
die fingerspitzen fehlt immer auch und
werden alle immer und dann den finger
er ist schlimmer als ein fitter nie ohne
finger chance mit hast du dich schon mal
geschnitten
sag jetzt mal nicht meine linke hand
aber auf jeden fall wandert kommt weg
danach online also am anfang war ich
immer so und sobald dann die kartoffel
so leicht verschwindet ihre daten wird
ja auch schon so ein in leder und dann
ruschel hatte und nachdem rockstar games
und nach dem benutzen immer gleich auf
null drehen okay aber jetzt keiner
schneide aber ich gebe dir über swing
tricks auf aber wenn du wenn du fertig
bist dann auf null
ok dass wir uns beim saubermachen nicht
schneiden
ich sehe mich auch voll die
gefahrenquelle in der küche
ja ja einfach das abziehen oder das team
verstärken muss ich so lange werde ich
wie schnell ich schmelz noch die butter
schmelzen eine art dankeschön gelte ja
so bin ich halt bin vorne zu dir also
die sind von mir das gerät hier
das finde ich gut der effekt sogar
noch so ein sagt ja du kannst einfach
drüber so wird er nächsten einsatz dann
kannst du auch schulleben schneiden
musste stiftung gewinn für jeden tag
jury beim ich schneide direkt aus
frankreich
die koppel gebe ich dann hier rein
ich finde ja auch echt schön mit schale
ist gut so ja es gibt so einfach eine
schöne optik natur
ja und jetzt mit salz und pfeffer
vermischen da kommt noch thymian
[Applaus]
wir sind wieder einsatzbereit sorry von
15 minuten für den zwischenfall
ich bin nicht ohnmächtig geworden sturm
ja auch nicht weil das wir saßen beide
voneinander
ich habe die bilder wieder aus dem kopf
verdrängt
okay aber unser menü das ist wundervoll
das muss glaube ich noch die kartoffeln
erholen oh ja stimmen die kartoffeln mit
thymian salz und pfeffer vermischen und
dann kommt so ein richtig schöner park
und rosmarie natürlich wollte mein auto
zu nehmen somit das muss man somit rein
das riecht doch gleich perfekt
jetzt kann ich auch schon mal den herd
ausmachen und das habe ich jetzt gesehen
das sieht echt mega cool aus da musste
jetzt bitte aufpassen dass du dich nicht
verbrennen
nämlich wie was und dann die kartoffeln
so fächer für mich einfach hier drauf
und das zieht dann am ende schon
ziemlich ziemlich gut aus guck mal die
kleinen die schmeiße ich so unten ein
dass die arbeit mache ich mich richtig
viel rauch ist das eine genugtuung
rosmarin ja bereits nach gefühl so viel
wie du möchtest dich also war jetzt mal
ganz schön
ich hoffe ich habe die richtige menge an
kartoffeln und ich glaube ich sie dir
das sieht wundervoll aus
das ist so ein rezept findig wenn du das
glück zur mama bringst da ist die mama
begeistert plötzlich ja oder sie zu
mensch da hat sie sich mühe gegeben und
die kartoffeln jeder einzelne hier an
gereiht
bitte bitte verbringen
was ist denn los jetzt einmal fehler
gemacht es jetzt eine kleine
fleischwunde kurz zusammengenäht ach so
vielleicht finden wir aus minecraft und
das dann jetzt mal drüber von außen nach
innen das herunter gedreht
und ja er ist ausgemacht damit sie nicht
blöd und wir uns nicht verbrennen
schafft das schon
ich lege zu die kleinen anfang zum
endstücke hier unten noch doch noch ein
dass die verschwunden sind und ich sehe
einfach mit verarbeite und optisch hat
auch dass ich die kleinen jetzt nicht
obendrauf legen habe was hattest du in
der schule tatsächlich erst mal fragen
so als kurse oberstufe oder genauer
oberstufe hatte leistungskurse deutsch
und englisch und grundkurse hat die nati
reinschmeißen bereitet das ist einfach
so dass er stirbt
ich hatte deutsch englisch
leistungskurse und geschichte und mathe
grundkurse also klassisches kartoffel
wie sage ich immer geschichte ich habe
geschichte gehasst wir werden halt im
besten lehrer der schule der
geschichtslehrer deswegen wollten dass
alle machen und er war richtig cool
unser geschichtslehrer war auch mega
cool das war echt so auch einer meiner
lieblings lehrer aber ich konnte mich
mit der geschichte gelernt wollen
ich dachte ich länder halten und dann
hatte ich noch meine einzige fünf bis
sechs in der schullaufbahn
das heißt ich kann geschichte nicht
wie kriegt ihr denn jetzt davon mich
reingelegt ich war hier schon außen
irgendwie einrichten ist dann hätte ich
hier noch mehr über müssten so über
fächern verbrennt dich nicht du nicht
wen ich hab' ich kann es schon eine
friteuse stecken hast du mein gold mega
viele kartoffeln
wir hatten gleich fehler das stimmt
überhaupt nicht dass mir viel mehr
gegeben und mich zu verunsichern und
jetzt bin ich unsicher
ein stück singer mit auflagen machen
können
ok guck mal ich habe mir noch bissl
rosmarin drauf einfach verlegen der
optik wegen des geschmacks dann wird die
kartoffel schlecht mit butter bestrichen
mit flüssiger für den geschmack und dann
darf das auch schon den backofen
wirklich schön niedriger temperatur dann
wird das fleisch schön zart im doppel
werden weich und wir können in der
zwischenzeit muss backen dort wirklich
gut damit auch groß unternehmer später
ein richtig leckeres mittagessen
abendessen dem gast auch immer in essen
hauptgericht und auf jeden fall mit
deckel kochen deswegen habe ich euch
hier den gusseisen topf gewählt haben
sonsten wenn ihr einem guss altintop
nicht habt könnt ihr auch eine
auflaufform nehmen und vorher natürlich
das gericht im topf kochen dann umfüllen
aber ihr solltet auf jeden fall abdecken
damit einfach das ganze geschmort wird
nicht trocken wird und wirklich schön
durchziehen kann
ich finde wir haben gut gekocht gelangen
muss in oben jetzt schon sagen schon
eine stunde schon stündchen okay schön
langsam passen perfekt
dann ab in den ofen
[Musik]
tom macht so etwas
durch diese sich gelegt ähnlich ja
oder ist der wert lag robert lassen kann
steht der komplette ein kochbuch steht
der geburt durch rühren oder
angesprochen dass ich jetzt glaube ich
einfach so schön raus schützt chance gut
aus so lecker das riecht so lecker boa
ich habe glaube ich tatsächlich mit dir
jetzt ist erst einmal damit zu bereiten
sie gemacht
das tribunal fürst das total wenig
eingeteilt so lange darauf geschaut wer
also heute sich so gut mit dem
hintergrund ich muss noch bilder machen
dann später probieren ich muss es ja
gleich schmecken ja auch für also
umsonst
jetzt nicht verbrennen ich hoffe es ist
zeit
doch so war ich musste erst mal zehn
minuten also ich kann auch heute noch
irgendwas 40 grad wow jetzt vollzeit
probieren sie mir für mich letztlich
schon gut weil unten die soße ist schon
noch so ruppig ich auch also muss nicht
immer so gebunden sein als man kann man
schön noch brot rein drucken bei mir
fehlten ticken salz aber ansonsten ich
habe das gefühl ich habe es gesagt ja na
siehst ja ich hab's nicht gesalzen fall
gut ich bin echt das wirklich sehr
lecker ich bin super super super was mit
viel blut verloren ich kann nicht mehr
reden eigentlich hatte hier hinten dran
unter anderem statt das war nicht so
viel doch war schon ein paar scheint
tief geschnitten
ich finds auch mega lecker ja und ich
fand es ist auch cool hier so partner
cooking zu machen an geräte parallel
echt schön war das wirklich
ja also probiert das rezept gerne mal
aus ich hoffe morath kocht auch mal mit
mir da kocht nie mit mir dass ich über
rädchen stimmung aber ich bin doch ein
angenehmer kochpartner ja auch sehr
guter lehrer
ich würde es mal gucken ja ich auch noch
mal ihr findet das rezept in meiner app
oder auf dem blog auf 6 - blockte eben
oder in der service welt app probiert
gerne mal aus danke strom mir dass du da
bist die komplette woche
wir haben viel spaß zusammen eine schöne
zeit
[Musik]